aulas va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
freiner les deux sens nous enfermer
selon la rhétorique de l'exécutif à
partir de minuit pour un noir plus de 20
millions de français dans seize
départements seront concernés par les
nouvelles restrictions
l'exécutif qui tente de rassurer c'est
ainsi sous l'oeil des caméras que jean
castex a reçu le vaccin d'astrazeneca
les injections repris ce vendredi mais
seulement pour les plus de 55 ans les
discussions se sont poursuivies
aujourd'hui à huis clos faux lendemain
de vifs échanges entre chinois et
américain joe biden s'est dit fier du
chef de la diplomatie américaine anthony
blinken
pour le premier face à face de leur bail
dernière en alaska les délégations des
deux premières puissances mondiales ont
étalé leurs désaccords de manière peu
diplomatique pour les états unis la
chine menacent la stabilité mondiale
pecqueur de son côté conseille
d'abandonner la mentalité de guerre
froide
[Musique]
il ya dix ans jour pour jour intervenue
en libye les forces occidentales on
appuie à l'insurrection populaire états
unis royaume uni et france lançait une
opération militaire contre mouammar
kadhafi
une décennie plus tard les stigmates de
la guerre sont toujours là et le pays
divisé
un nouveau gouvernement on vient d'être
formé chargé de mener la libye jusqu'à
des élections nationales en décembre
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france journalistes et
caméras télévision était au rendez vous
cet après midi pour filmer la séquence
jean castex qui a reçu une première
injection d'astrazeneca opération
rassurer les français pour le premier
ministre
voilà plusieurs jours que le sérum du
laboratoire suédois britannique est
pointée du doigt après des cas de
caillots sanguins observées chez des
moins de 55 ans qu'il y en a eu trois en
france après sa suspension la haute
autorité de santé a finalement donné son
feu vert ce matin la reprise de la
vaccination avec astrazeneca tout en
recommandant de le réserver désormais
aux plus de 55 ans l'om est déclare à
nouveau ce soir que les bénéfices
l'emportent sur les risques pas
d'incidence supplémentaire de troubles
de coagulation
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé jean castex qui a annoncé hier
soir de nouvelles restrictions pour 16
départements dont l'île de france il
s'agit de freiner le virus sont nous
enfermer selon la rhétorique de
l'exécutif
pour emmanuel macron le mot au
confinement ne serait donc pas adapté à
partir de minuit pour au moins en mois
fermeture des commerces non essentiel en
terreau diction des déplacements inter
régionaux et attestation obligatoire
pour toute sortie alors ces nouvelles
mesures arrivent trop tard
éléments de réponse avec clémence pital
et grégoire pousset l'exécutif at il
joué avec le feu à la suite du
confinement de novembre qui n'a pas eu
les résultats escomptés en termes de
baisse du nombre de contaminations
le gouvernement voulait à tout prix
éviter une nouvelle mise sous cloche
objectif maintenir l'activité économique
autant que possible et éviter de donner
un nouveau coup au moral des français
problème les variants apparaissent et
complique sérieusement le contrôle de
l'épidémie
s'ensuit alors un enchaînement de
mesures intermédiaires couvre-feu avancé
à 18h sur tout le territoire dès la
mi-janvier confinement le week end dans
les zones où les indicateurs inquiète le
plus jusqu'à ce confinement 7 jours sur
7 pour un tiers de la population
depuis le début de l'année le
gouvernement fait le pari de ne pas
opter pour un confinement globalisé
évoquant même par moment un horizon plus
dégagé
si nous considérions qu'il fallait
aujourd'hui un confinement
nous aurions décidé d'un concile
on est donc tous nos efforts tous nos
efforts doivent se poursuivre pour
éviter d'avoir à décider d'un nouveau
confinement nationale pour la première
fois depuis des mois maintenant le
retour à des vie plus normale est en vue
nos sorties notre sport notre culture
tous nos exutoire tous ces lieux qui
font notre vie sociale rouvriront il est
vrai que le nombre de contaminations a
longtemps stagné
tout en restant sur un plateau élevé
mais l'éventualité d'un emballement avec
des cas de variants majoritaire à terme
devenait une menace pressante
une information dont disposaient les
autorités dès la fin janvier le conseil
scientifique alerte l'état dans une note
dévoilée aux français seulement 27 jours
plus tard alors que selon le code de la
santé publique
ces documents auraient dû être publiés
sans délai le panel d'experts préconise
alors un confinement strict de quatre
semaines dès le mois de février pour
reprendre réellement la maîtrise des
contaminations et ralentir la
progression des six problématique
variant sur le terrain les
professionnels de santé ont également
très tôt tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
sans être véritablement entendu exemple
à l'hôpital de grasse dans les alpes
maritimes
je pense que le confinement guy férez
inévitable alain pour améliorer les
choses rapidement
un service qui est plein tous les jours
on a 22 lits disponibles pour les
hospitalisations kovy débat tous les
jours en est à 22 patients 1 malgré
qu'on fasse quand même des sorties
quotidiennes des sponsors 5 6 patients
n'en rentre autant ce qu'on pourrait se
dire et éthiquement c'est qu'un
couvre-feu plus intense plus peut-être
plus dur nous permettrait de retrouver à
une vie sans couvre-feu à terme une mise
sous cloche préventive aurait à coup sûr
désengorger les services de réanimation
et réduit le nombre de contaminations
mais difficile de savoir si cela aurait
empêché une énième reprise de l'épidémie
post confinement le timing d'une telle
mesure semble donc relever d'un
véritable numéro d'équilibriste trop tôt
le confinement n'emporte pas l'adhésion
des français trop tard on prend le
risque d'augmenter la mortalité le
confinement est forcément plus dur
plus long régulièrement critiqué pour sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire
le gouvernement est une nouvelle fois
attendu au tournant à propos d'une
situation à nouveau particulièrement
préoccupante
une nouvelle restriction dénoncée par
les oppositions et les commerçants
contrant une nouvelle fois de baisser le
rideau foule leur essai de martial
peuvion nouveau confinement rime avec
nouvelle fermeture alors que seuls les
magasins de première nécessité resteront
ouverts durant ces quatre semaines
cette mise sous cloche est perçue comme
un véritable coup de massue pour les
autres ces commerçants contraints de
fermer leurs boutiques pour la troisième
fois en un an sont découragés enfin sauf
que séoul et qu'on dise même si on rate
ça va râler dans le vent on est obligé
de subir mais après moi je trouve qu'on
paye pour les gens qui font pas
attention tout simplement je pense que
si on avait su on faisait tous attention
on n'en serait peut-être pas là sans ce
moment là j'ai pas envie de me plaindre
parce que ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
voilà
et si compliqué pour tout le monde et
pour eux aussi donc ouais c'est désolant
c'est regrettable mais on n'y peut rien
certains prétendent que l'état manque de
considération envers leur profession ils
se sentent abandonnés et réclament plus
de solutions on va surtout aussi que
falloir que l'état comme le premier
ministre nous l'a indiqué début de
semaine que l'état trouve des solutions
pour nous les commerces qui sont fermés
notamment le prêt-à-porter le
prêt-à-porter
on a vraiment l'impression d'être les
grands oubliés de cette crise sanitaire
par rapport aux aides outre
l'impossibilité d'accéder à ces
commerces dits non essentiels les
nouvelles règles de circulation sont
parfois jugés contradictoires et compter
certains habitants concernés par le
confinement n'hésite pas à faire part de
leur lassitude
tout le monde reste un peu dans la
compréhension c'est un confinement qui
on n'est pas vraiment à et tout le monde
sera au courant qu'on préférerait
peut-être finalement être vraiment
confiné pour essayer de vraiment passé
ce virus mais là on a l'impression qu'on
cherche à tourner un peu autour du pot
pour faire quelque chose qui a beaucoup
de gens qui vont en souffrir notamment
en vrai les commerçants c'est ça en fait
c'est qu'on se dit que finalement le
virus circule surtout finalement à
l'école et au boulot etc les deux seuls
endroits où les gens ont le droit
d'aller donc c'est
que c'est très contradictoires qu'on n'a
pas le moral vraiment on a pu rien pour
eux c'est vivre pour manger dormir être
clos après c'est comme une prison
les 16 régions confiné dès ce week-end
représente 21 millions d'habitants dont
12 millions en région parisienne des
mesures décrétées pour au moins quatre
semaines est susceptible d'être étendue
selon l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire en grande difficulté dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire le voyagiste
tui shou va licencier en france 573
employés sur les 904 présents dans
l'hexagone un licenciement en
licenciement de masse qui a été validé
par la justice hier le tribunal
administratif de cergy qui a débouté les
salariés qu'il contestait à
l'homologation du plan de sauvegarde de
l'emploi par la direction régionale du
travail
benoît martin secrétaire général de la
cgt paris s'inquiète de l'avenir des
salariés concernés il ya un problème de
se priver de centaines de salariés qui
n'y seront plus là lorsque le secteur du
tourisme va redémarrer dans j'espère la
fin d'année peut être content éluder les
campagnes de vaccination un peu partout
dans le monde et donc ce serait une
entreprise démunis privé de la plupart
de ses salariés qui devra remettre en
route le secteur du voyage mais
également s'il ya des problèmes sur la
forme des des suppressions d'emplois
prévues pas assez de reclassement pas à
passer d'une sécurisation des parcours
professionnels de ces gens là qui se
sont investis dans un métier qu'ils
aiment en tant que royalistes une crise
sanitaire qui conduit à des situations
kafkaïennes depuis maintenant trois
semaines 25 algériens sont ainsi
bloquées dans la zone internationale de
l'aéroport paris-charles de gaulle et
ses ressortissants algériens soit ait
séjourné dans leur pays d'origine les
autorités algériennes
leur demande de retourner en grande
bretagne dans une résidence en raison de
la pandémie selon l'ambassade de
l'algérie à paris il avait été mise au
courant de l'annulation de leur vie de
leur billet une information qu'il
démente
ils vivent depuis dans des conditions
très rudimentaire c'est un reportage de
monaco dès lors il me trouve
actuellement à l'aéroport paris charles
de gaulle au terminal 2e là où se
trouvent les algériens bloqués depuis
plusieurs jours
le but est d'aller leur donner la parole
et voir dans quelle condition
bonjour voila je suis bloqué depuis le
26 février et à l'aéroport de roissy
charles de gaulle de là naîtront
celui-là même si on voit tous les jours
des avions d'air france
un des cent en avril avec depuis le 26
février
c'est ici que dorment les 25 passagers
dont des enfants des femmes âgées est un
homme atteint d'un cancer en vérifiant
la nuit
mais les casques en général en
couverture et laisser d'organes a reçu
quelques calculs y indiquant flaherty
peu de ruptures
c'est jamais est la cousine qui dort sur
ses fauteuils tient à nous montrer ou
dans sa fille de 4 ans et une autre
enfant ça c'est pour les petits fruits
ça c'est par là
bien qu'ils soient munis de leur
passeport tests pcr et attestations de
rapatriement de l'ambassade d'algérie à
londres
air algérie leur refuse l'embarquement à
partir du 26 février le 1er mars
les vols de rapatriement sont suspendus
jusqu'au 31 mars
en vo par an
on sait par deux fois on est là une
situation qui a provoqué un élan de
solidarité et des anonymes fournissent
de la nourriture et à boire un soutien
primordial pour karim
son but s'organise au sol dans les
universités vraiment difficile avec les
algériens marocains et tunisiens
les ressortissants exhorte le
gouvernement algérien à prendre
rapidement des mesures comme cette
passagère en état pour le thé monsieur
le président vous avez dit que vous ne
laisserai jamais un algérien se faire
humilier à l'étranger laissez-nous
rentrer chez nous s'il vous plaît
c'est tout ce que l'on demande monsieur
teboul tripoli contacté par rt france
l'ambassade d'algérie en france indique
que les ressortissants algériens avaient
été informés le 25 février de
l'annulation de leur billet avant qu'il
quitte le royaume uni une information
confirmée par zoé laouali représentant
d'air algérie en france mais démentie
par les passagers rencontrés je peux
vous envoyer des vidéos informé par du
helmand mais ils ont été on a fait de
notre mieux pour pouvoir dès public est
informé
il avait des attestations de
rapatriement pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
pas pu continuer leur chemin jusqu'à
alger
nous avons sollicité la nouvelle
ambassade pour les attestations de
rapatriement en vain
selon les passagers bloqués ces derniers
jours certains algériens bénéficierez de
passe droit et aurait pu voyager pour
motif impérieux avec la compagnie air
france de son côté aéroports de paris
affirme que cette situation est du
ressort des autorités algériennes
ils sont en zone internationale dans une
salle d'embarquement ce n'est pas un
hôtel nous essayons de tout faire
nous avons fourni des couvertures nous
avons aussi ouvert des douches
s'il faut faire des tests pcr rapidement
nous le ferons nous n'avons pas les
leviers pour agir sur cette situation
en attendant les frontières algériennes
fermé depuis le 17 mars 2020 depuis le
26 février
aucune proposition de rapatriement n'a
été proposée aux ressortissants
algériens
il demande aux dirigeants politiques des
réponses concrètes à la crise climatique
voilà près de deux ans et demi et que le
mouvement used for climate s'activent en
faveur du climat
il appelait en ce vendredi 19 mars à la
mobilisation de la jeunesse
un rassemblement était notamment
organisée à paris rassemblement cas
suivi notre reporter ton abonnés
plusieurs milliers de jeunes réunis dans
les rues de la capitale à l'appel
d'organisations politiques syndicales ou
encore associative pour protester contre
la loi climat qui est en train d'être
examiné à l'assemblée nationale une loi
qui ne va pas assez loin selon les
manifestants
ici ils reprochent au gouvernement de ne
pas avoir pris la mesure des enjeux de
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique ils se considèrent même comme
une génération sacrifiée beaucoup de
jeunes voire de très jeunes ici présents
cet après midi je propose d'écouter
quelques témoignages recueillis avec
baptiste gosses là qu'on veut pas être
la génération sacrifiée la génération
sacrifiée à la fois à cause de la
précarité mais aussi à cause des
réformes climat à cause d'eux du coup
franc climatique face auxquels on est
face auquel le gouvernement ne fait rien
l'état français a déjà été condamné pour
une action climatique
aujourd'hui il a essayé de prendre un
peu sa revanche de faire une belle
communication autour d'une convention
climat la réalité c'est qu'il ne prend
plus aucune de leurs propositions
quasiment l'elysée aujourd'hui s'est
transformé en agence de communication
nous on a des revendications et on a des
propositions pour le climat il faut
faire la transition énergétique
il faut planifier la bifurcation
écologique on peut pas continuer à
produire aujourd'hui comme on produisait
hier 20 d'antan mouvement
qu'ils représentent les différentes
luttes et qui ne passe pas par un
individu et qui défend ses propres
intérêts en fait on veut des engagements
dans le temps pour nous pour les
français mais aussi pour eux
pour tout ce qu'il ya autour de nous
pour notre environnement nos socios
l'écosystème en fait on veut de vrais
engagements et ça c'est difficile quand
on a en représentant qui veut se faire
élire qui va du coup se battre pour son
élection en fait seulement pour son
élection nous on veut des gens qui ont
des vraies convictions et qui vont se
battre jusqu'au bout mais surtout qu'ils
vont se battre avec nous on veut pas
être exclue on va être entendu on veut
faire partie de tous les processus en
fait en plus des enjeux climatiques il
ya donc aussi la question de la
précarité étudiante on sait la crise
sanitaire a fortement impacté les
étudiants qui pour certains sont tombés
dans la précarité et c'est aussi une des
raisons donc qui a poussé certaines
personnes a participé à cette
manifestation
cet après midi beaucoup de personnes ici
nous expliquer que les enjeux
climatiques mais aussi donc de précarité
seront très importants pour eux en 2022
parce que pour certains d'entre eux ce
sera la première fois qu'ils pourront
voter à une élection présidentielle
c'est à huis clos que les disques sur se
sont poursuivies ce vendredi entre la
chine et les états unis au lendemain de
l'état l'âge de leur profond désaccord
premier face à face de l'herbe hayden
entre les deux puissances marquée par
des discours d'ouverture peu
diplomatique le président américain
s'est dit aujourd'hui fière de son chef
de la diplomatie anthony blinken
retour sur ces vifs les échanges hier
avec solène gaudin climat tendu en
alaska à l'issue d'une réunion de deux
jours entre la chine et les états unis
elle les représentants des deux pays
campent sur leurs positions
la partie américaine a sérieusement
dépassé le délai convenu lors de
l'allocution d'ouverture et à lancer les
attaques et des accusations sans
fondement
contre la politique intérieure et
étrangère de la chine et provoquer des
différents projets dans ce n'est ni la
bonne façon d'accueillir des hôtes ni
compatible avec le protocole
diplomatique
la crèche les deux parties dégager une
forte et dramatique odeur de poudre à
canon dès le début des allocutions
d'ouverture
ce n'était pas l'intention initiale de
la partie chinoise en cause l'immixtion
des états unis dans les affaires
internes chinoise pas du tout du goût de
la puissance asiatique
hier à l'ouverture des discussions
anthony blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a abordé des dossiers
brûlants
nous allons discuter de nos profondes
inquiétudes au sujet des actes de la
chine s'agissant du xinjiang de hong
kong de taïwan des cyber attaques contre
les états unis et de la coercition
économie contre nos alliés chacun de ces
actes menace un ordre fondé sur des
règles qui garantissent la stabilité
mondiale
c'est pourquoi il ne s'agit pas
seulement de questions intérieures et
nous ressentons l'obligation d'en parler
ici aujourd'hui une passe d'armes en
terrain miné
anthony blinken venait de rentrer d'une
tournée au japon et en corée du sud dont
l'objectif était de consolider les
alliances américaine dans la région et à
la veille de cette réunion a encore
eight washington a annoncé des sanctions
contre une vingtaine de responsables
chinois lié à la reprise en main de hong
kong par pékin
cette première rencontre entre les
etats-unis et la chine depuis l'élection
de joe biden s'achève sont laissé
entrevoir pour l'instant la possibilité
d'un apaisement entre ces deux
puissances mondiales un job hayden
offensif envers la chine mais aussi
envers la russie
n'hésitant pas à qualifier mercredi à
vladimir poutine de tueurs dans un
entretien diffusé par nbc le président
américain a assuré que son homologue
russe paierait les conséquences des
ingérences électorale a supposé de
moscou faisant le dernier scrutin
présidentiel
dans la foulée moscou fera rappeler son
ambassadeur aux etats-unis pour
consultations sur les moyens de corriger
la relation russo-américaine l'admirent
poutine assure que son pays maintiendra
des relations et continuera à travailler
avec les américains
tant que les conditions seront
avantageuses pour la russie il propose
par ailleurs une discussion en direct
avec son homologue diffuser ces
prochains jours
les propos de joe biden qui ont choqué
écoutez et ses réactions à moscou je
pense que le président d'un pays ne peut
pas parler comme ça du président d'un
autre pays
je dirais qu'il n'est pas très malin le
président byden disons que ce vieil
homme souffre de sénilité mieux qu'il
pense au président de son propre pays et
se demandent combien de gens têtus et
par qui le calcul sera simple alors je
ne suis pas d'une responsable politique
mais j'aimerais bien que les relations
même pendant les périodes compliquées
rappelez-vous la crise des missiles de
cuba on a su gérer tout cela
peut-être qu'à l'époque on avait un
dirigeant américain plus raisonnable qui
n'attirait pas les tensions
je ne voudrais portement pense que cela
porte atteinte à la hiérarchie politique
personne n'a le droit de parler ainsi
surtout au niveau politique
une nouvelle la prise de position
clivante sur la scène internationale
alors que les premières décisions
concrètes se font attendre deux mois
après son investiture la stratégie
diplomatique de john dryden reste en
effet en certaines robes actuel joe
biden réoriente la diplomatie américaine
retour dans les traités internationaux
hostilité affichée à l'encontre de la
russie
remise en cause du soutien à l'arabie
saoudite depuis son entrée en fonction
le président américain a multiplié les
prises de position avec un objectif
clair rompre avec la stratégie de son
prédécesseur donald trump un choix
réaffirmé dès le début du mois de
février lors de son premier discours sur
la politique internationale prononcé au
département d'état
l'amérique est de retour l'amérique est
de retour et la diplomatie est de retour
c est au centre de tout ce que j'ai
l'intention de faire nous allons réparer
nos alliances nous engager à nouveau
avec le monde non pas pour relever les
défis d'hier mais ceux d'aujourd'hui et
de demain
le leadership américain doit faire face
à ce nouveau moment de progression de
l'autoritarisme mais deux mois après
l'investiture de joe biden les décisions
fermes sur les dossiers brûlants se font
attendre
comme par exemple à propos du nucléaire
iranien joe biden a fait du retour des
etats unis dont l'accord devienne une
priorité mais sans actes concrets
washington semble encore bien éloigné de
la table des négociations
une forme d'inaction qui interroge de
plus en plus outre atlantique et qui
fait craindre une aggravation de la
situation
je pense que l'administration maiden a
raté une occasion au cours des premières
semaines de son mandat d'envoyer un
signal plus fort et plus concret de ses
intentions de bonne foi de revenir dans
l'accord de vienne pendant le temps
qu'il a fallu à l'équipe biden pour
commencer à être plus proactive les
positions se sont durcies en iran
surnommé joe lando remis par donald
trump au cours de la campagne
présidentielle
joe biden tente d'afficher des positions
incisive sur la scène internationale
avec le risque comme son prédécesseur de
fragiliser les discussions avec certains
partenaires internationaux
quel bilan tirer de l'intervention
militaire étrangère en libye c'était il
ya dix ans jour pour jour un appui chez
à l'insurrection populaire
les forces occidentales lançait une
opération contre mouammar kadhafi
aujourd'hui la libye et divisez 100 des
en deux les entités rivales se bat pour
un pays plongé dans une crise économique
et sécuritaire sans précédent katia
technique le 20 octobre 2011 mouammar
kadhafi et tués par des miliciens libyen
un espoir de liberté de construction
d'un bon système politique comme
l'annoncé les démocraties qui ont
précipité sa chute
dix ans après le déclenchement de
l'intervention est clair de la coalition
quel est le bilan sous alimentation
crise instabilité politique
montée de l'islamisme un état où
pullulent désormais les groupes armés
auxquels sont associés des tortures des
détentions arbitraires des attaques d
enlèvement d trafic de migrants
un bien triste anniversaire les premiers
morts civils tombent en février 2011
décrit par la presse comme des
populations inspiré par le printemps
arabe
au cours des semaines suivantes le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
vote de résolutions 1970 et 1973 elle
impose un embargo sur les armes et le
respect d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
les états membres de la coalition
vont-elles et plus loin et décide de
mettre en action tous les moyens
nécessaires pour protéger selon eux les
civils libyens
l'opération odyssey dawn sous la
houlette des etats-unis est donc mise en
place loin de s'en tenir à veiller sur
les populations
elle lance des frappes aériennes contre
les forces gouvernementales libyennes
l'otan assure le commandement militaire
de l'intervention à partir du mois
d'avril
la france va même jusqu'à douter les
rebelles en armes pour renverser le
pouvoir libyen et ce malgré l'embargo de
l'onu l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord refuse cessez le feu
que mouammar kadhafi propose rapidement
en lieu et place d'une solution pacifier
les rebelles se sont vus renforcée ont
donc contribué au basculement dans la
guerre civile
au cours de ces dernières années le pays
principalement déchiré entre deux camps
le gouvernement d'union nationale de
fayat zèle sa rage et l'armée nationale
libyenne dirigée par khalifa haftar
alors quels enseignements ont été tirés
de cette politique occidentale de la
terre brûlée
barack obama a lui même fini par
reconnaître qu'il s'était trompé
pire erreur probablement l'échec de la
préparation de la presse un coin ce qui
était la bonne chose à faire
dont l'intervention en libye en 2019
sergueï lavrov au ministre des affaires
étrangères russe avait ainsi critiqué
l'opération de l'alliance
la guerre civile en libye qui s'est
longuement prolonger résulte de
l'intervention militaire illégitime de
l'otan ce qui a fait basculer le pays
dans le chaos
et on a fait une source d'instabilité
dans la région est un terrain fertile
pour le terrorisme et même emmanuel
macron a reconnu ce fiasco en 2018
responsabilité qui a conduit quoi qu'on
pense d'un dirigeant d'imaginer qu'on
pouvait se substituer à la souveraineté
d'un peuple pour décider de son futur
nous avons collectivement
en plongée les libye depuis ses années
dans l'anomie sans pouvoir régler la
situation
il faut dire que la france a largement
contribué à la réalisation de cette
opération sous l'impulsion de nicolas
sarkozy ce dernier avait motivé son
action aux prétendants mettre un terme
je cite à la folie meurtrière d'un
régime qui en assassinant son propre
peuple
les relations financières entre nicolas
sarkozy et moi marc kadhafi viennent
encore assombrir le regard porté à cette
guerre et chacun pourra faire son mea
culpa
alors que reste-t-il aux libyens leur
pays champ de bataille en proie à la
guerre civile est aussi ruiner jadis
prospère grâce à ses réserves de pétrole
il a vu tous les investisseurs fuir à
cause de l'instabilité politique une
crise économique sans précédent
accablent le pays mais il est notamment
par une inflation galopante
tout juste leur reste-t-il de la
perspective d'élections en fin d'année
un espoir après dix ans de chaos tandis
que les dirigeants occidentaux à
l'origine de cette catastrophe se sont
retirés de l'arène politique
1 c'est la fin de ce journal on se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour nous pour une nouvelle édition tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés